[Music]
unforgettable so unforgettable is a very
forgettable movie starring Katherine
Heigl and rosario Dawson involvement
Katherine Heigl in this movie plays this
really crazy obsessive ex to this dude
and rosario Dawson is in the unfortunate
scenario of being in this movie at all
he's in the unfortunate scenario and
having to be a stepmom like or our
future stepmom when she's dating
Katherine Heigl's ex and they have a kid
together so she's in the tough spot if
she wants to bond with this kid dude has
a crazy act let me be clear in stating
that none of this with the kid
matters because I guess at a point in
this movie they're totally bonded and
you didn't really see it progress I
skipped out on a Star Wars party for
this I just felt you should know rosario
Dawson tries her best she acts circles
around a lot of people in this movie the
script is the worst Katherine I come
Algar you look at fatal attraction fatal
attraction was suspenseful because this
lady started out seeming kind of normal
then she turned nuts and you're like oh
my gosh she was always nuts maybe
someone who seems normal is crazy oh my
god should I get into romances at all
you never know this movie from the first
look she's like crazy crazy eyes on me I
mean I mean granted at first you feel
like oh hey what's up you should just
look at you like that you like that no
no just go and take her myself
thanks dad Ingrid she reminded me of the
TX from Terminator 3 I can always just
they're over playing their hand at being
robotic Lee crazy Rosario Dawson's
characters X's in them but there's no
real progression it doesn't develop
there's no real arc is just kind of this
thing that's happening in the background
there's all right bum here now it comes
in out now is over and the end is the
worst like the end of the movie the
climax of the movie is a literal word is
it as bad as the last act of the boy
next door I really don't know yeah I
think it is so much of this movie and
Katherine Heigl's master plan hinges on
shitty communication among supposed to
healthy relationships she keeps calling
rosario Dawson and hanging up and it's
kind of driving rosario Dawson not when
Azaria Dawson could just feel like ever
get in prank callers should be let's
just block the phone number let's block
a phone number because we have a
landline in 2017 and that's the other
thing this movie hinges on is landlines
at the end who the intense crazy is
coming after Azaria Dawson who calls
9-1-1 Katherine Heigl rips the landline
out can't call now a lamp
we're back in the Clinton years I
didn't know that alright I guess oh
we're not because they all have iPhone
that when the script calls for it they
leave in the car leave in the
car when's the last time you did that
when's the last time you left your phone
in the car especially when you know you
might have to call 911 a second who
doesn't walk out and be like funky
wallet done it's tap tap tap you know
every time you get out of your you
don't do that well I guess I'm the
only one who's crazy proof I'm not all
the fans I flirt with on social media
wanting is going to snap and I'm going
to be glad I go tap tap tap and know
where my cell phone is guys in the end
it's monstrosity you should not
watch it
nor should it have been made I really
hope rosario dawson doesn't take too big
a hit from this Katherine Heigl I didn't
even know you were acting still if this
was your comeback it's also your swan
song that sucks
unforgettable is forgettable dog
alright guys so since you're not going
to watch this movie what is the
shittiest thriller you have seen ever or
recently whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here that's e more
[Music]